hallo leute ich ist wieder eure mal
wanne und willkommen zu einem neuen
video und ihr habt es in titel schon
richtig gelesen titel im titel habt ihr
schon richtig gelesen heute testen wir
asus outfits immer geil wenn ich hier
stehe habe ich gleich wieder dieses
klaglos denn wie ihr unschwer erkennen
könnt ist mein klamotten stil so jeans
und t shirt und damit bin ich eigentlich
auch sehr zufrieden doch wenn man in der
fashion stadt berlin lebt merkt man dass
da noch viel luft nach oben ist und
gerade wenn ich bei asus bestellen
möchte fällt mir oft auf dass die
outfits sehr crazy sind und ich sie
niemals zu bestellen würde weil traue
ich mich einfach nicht und das ist heute
unser ziel vielleicht finde ich ja mein
neuen fashion stil und wird zu einer
richtigen fashion bloggerin
ich zeige euch jetzt mal was ich so
bestellt habe
[Musik]
also lasst uns starten
wir starten mit diesem leo outfit muss
ehrlich sagen ich besitze kein teil was
ein leopard war für mich leoprint immer
so einen komischen beigeschmack hat und
so ein leo outfit würde persönlich auch
nur zum fasching glaube ich tragen aber
ich will ja fashion wanne werden also
letters crisis on rom ein
eine sache die mir bei den outfits
aufgefallen ist unten wird immer
vorgeschlagen was man nachkaufen kann um
dieses outfit nach zu kaufen und sie
machen immer teurere artikel rein als
sie eigentlich sind also diese schwarzen
schuhe die hier sehen könnt die werden
vorgeschlagen dass man sich halt doc
martens holt aber das sind eigentlich
monkey schuhe und die monkey schuhe
verkaufen sie auch deswegen muss man gut
suchen oder man kauft sich doc martens
wenn man das geld hat dann gehe ich
jetzt ab in die zauberkugel
ja
[Musik]
outfit nummer eins ich finde dem model
auf basis hat es besser gestanden als
mia ich muss aber sagen ich finde es
cooler als ich gedacht hätte ich weiß
jetzt nicht ob ich mich trauen würde so
auf die straße zu gehen aber schon
statement schon mit dem auto sagt man
schon ich lebe in berlin was los meine
eltern haben mich gar nichts zu sagen ja
das oberteil habe ich nur in größe l
bekommen weil bei als es um alles so
schnell ausverkauft ist es warum glück
dass ich überhaupt das gekriegt habe ich
weiß auch gar nicht ob man jetzt noch
die sachen kaufen kann ihr könnt ja mal
schauen
falls ich irgendwas davon super gut
gefällt es kommen wieder zum nächsten
outfit das zweite haut ist auf jeden
fall tragbare als das erste trotzdem bin
ich noch nicht auf die idee gekommen so
eine mütze zu tragen oder so einen
bunten rock würde ich eigentlich auch
nicht tragen und die schule ja ich trage
halt auch nicht so wirklich hohe schuhe
deswegen fand ich jetzt mal witzig das
auszuprobieren also ab in die
zauberkugel
[Musik]
ich liebe einfach das leben aber ich
glaube am liebsten durch paris und macht
tolle fotos sind im café ja ich trink
doch gerne kraft mein café allgemeine
bewertung zu diesem outfit ja diese
mütze ich verstehe schon warum sie viele
tragen die sieht schon echt fesch aus
aber wie mein kameramann und ich uns
einig sind das ist halt eine oper mütze
sollte man auch den opels lassen die
haben eine sache eine oper mütze und die
sollte man den wirklich lassen
meine wertung zu diesem outfit ich finde
es einst spitzenklasse ich finde den
hooton bis hin zu viel das ist aber okay
das ist geschmackssache ich finde aber
diesen rock toll obwohl er sich so ganze
zeit elektrisiert also der ist ganz nah
an meinem bein weil einfach daran klebt
glaubt er sollte eigentlich ein bisschen
lustiger sein pulli ist auch ok ist ist
aber nicht der den das model trägt aber
sie ziemlich ähnlich aus und jetzt kommt
meine persönliche überraschung die
schuhe
ich habe mich so in diese schule verlegt
sie sind auch nicht die originale aus
dem outfit aber recht ähnlich ich finde
die aber so schön ich würde mit diesem
outfit auf jeden fall raus gehen wenn
die leute mich auf der straße sehen
würden wenn sie sagen ja sie hat das
fashion game verstanden bikini und mit
dem aufstieg angebot machen wie gefällt
euch schreibt in die kommentare
jetzt kommen wir wohl zum extremsten out
für dort
ich weiß nicht zu welchen anlässen man
dieses outfit tragen sollte außer mannes
rapperin oder hat ein fans wie instagram
account aber dafür ist dieses video ja
da vielleicht gefällt es mir richtig gut
wir werden sehen in unserer zauberkugel
mein gott diese jacke
[Musik]
[Applaus]
walking the mystery train
man kann darin gar nicht laufen ohne
irgendwie ganz locker machen
zum anschleichen ist die jacke perfekt
macht den otto anschleichen
ich schaffe es jetzt einmal ordentlich
zu geben ist schon wieder fashion week
für ein rap video ist das outfit
wirklich perfekt ich weiß nicht ob ich
privat damit raus gehen könnte also mit
den schul definitiv nicht die schuhe die
zu erstellen deine füße ein bei nicht wo
finde ich das gar nicht mal so schlecht
wenn ein meter rücken kann auch
entzücken fashion ich hatte noch
ohrringe bestellt aber die kam irgendwie
nicht an keine ahnung wo die sind ja es
ist wahr
kommen wir zu unserem vierten outfit das
vierte outfit ist glaube ich mein
lieblingsort führt weil es diesen girlie
boss weiter ich glaube mit dem outfit
wird man richtig ernst genommen auf der
straße und sieht aus wie eine business
frau und es hat carus was zurzeit sehr
in mode wieder ist wie allerdings habe
ich die blaue handtasche nicht gefunden
dafür habe ich aber eine hübsche
alternative gesehen die ich genauso
passend finde also lasst uns in die
zauberkugel
[Musik]
also ganz ehrlich dieses outfit finde
ich bis jetzt am besten denn es sieht
einfach nur cool lässig schick also es
hat irgendwie was von allem
ich finde es sieht richtig angezogen aus
also du siehst so aus als ob du dir auch
gedanken darum gemacht das was du an
hast aber gleichzeitig auch so locker
das ist einfach perfekt es hat von allem
etwas
die schuhe sind allerdings vor mir das
sieht man vielleicht an der farbe ich
hatte keine bis neue zu kaufen ich habe
weiße schuhe ich brauche nicht noch mehr
ich kann coole tricks und meiner tasche
irgendwie so eine brotdose aber auch
ganz cool
jetzt bin ich aber auch echt gespannt
das team auf wird sagt denn man kann es
lieben oder hassen glaube ich ich weiß
nicht was sie sich bei dem t shirt
gedacht haben denn das ist einfach xxl
das ist ein l t shirt weil sie natürlich
schon wieder nicht die em hatten oder
die s2 bei asus immer alles sofort
ausverkauft ist
das muss man halt schön reinstecken und
ich hab fünf kilo mehr drauf bekommen
wir zu unserem letzten outfit und zwar
dieser funky fresh festival lockt den
ich unbedingt mal ausprobieren wollte
weil ich auf festivals eigentlich immer
aus wie ich nur mit gummistiefeln und
das sieht so süß und kind und passend
aus dass ich das unbedingt ausprobieren
muss also ab ein letztes mal in die
zauberkugel
[Musik]
nein
neben
wer bei aussagen
der song ist
[Musik]
si
zunächst fällt
[Musik]
ihr wundert euch wohl meine regenjacke
ist kein problem denn diese praktische
bauchtasche ist nicht nur eine
bauchtasche sondern auch die regenjacke
können sie eine gute verkäuferin sein
einmal auf riemer geschwungen und der
regen kann euch nichts mehr erster
eindruck von diesem outfit die
regenjacke ist mega cool und super
praktisch dass man sie so wegpacken kann
die gummistiefel passend dazu das ist
ein tolles gesamtbild allerdings ist
diese hose viel zu kurz ich werde
einfach nie ein freund von so kurzen
hosen sein und das t shirt gefällt mir
auch sehr gut das ist sehr gut das war
das fünfte und letzte outfit und jetzt
kommen wir zum fazit soll ich denn
irgendwie so springt ich dachte ich
probiere mal aus ein outfits 1 zusammen
zu stellen also war do you think
ich muss sagen ich bin sehr stolz auf
mich ich finde dieses outfit sehr cool
und ich würde damit auch auf die straße
gehen eure punktzahl bitte jetzt in die
kommentare wenn ehrlich aus dem
leoparden outfit habe ich kein
teilgenommen weil naja das hat mir jetzt
auch nicht so gut gefallen das outfit
mit dem karierten blazer hat mir
persönlich am besten gefallen weil ich
das gefühl hatte mich nicht so wirklich
zu verkleiden bei dem leoparden outfit
da habe ich mich gefühlt wie ein
karneval bei dem festival outfit auch
bei dem ghetto hip hop lederjacken lack
und lederjacken outfit war das war
sowieso nicht ich und deswegen war dass
das mit dem jackett in wie am coolsten
ich finde aber das auto was ich jetzt
zusammengestellt habe gefällt mir noch
einen ticken besser also die schuhe ich
habe mich wirklich in diese schuhe
verliebt ich hätte niemals gedacht dass
ich solche schuhe gut befinden könnte
aber ein loch sam und ich liebe auch
diese adidas hose der hat so einen
leichten asita sie schick gemischt in
der zukunft will ich auf jeden fall
versuchen öfter aus meiner komfortzone
heraus zu kommen und mal teile zu nehmen
bei denen ich jetzt nicht auf den ersten
blick sagen würde
das werde ich tragen weil dieses jackett
hätte ich niemals bestellt wenn es nicht
für dieses video gewesen wäre aber ich
weiß jetzt ganz genau dass ich das
tragen werde weil ich mich super wohl
darin fühle
genauso wie in dieser hose und in diesem
verdammten schufen die sind sogar super
bequem ich hätte niemals die sehen so
unbequem aus und die sind so bequem ihr
glaubt gar nicht und das war es auch
schon wieder mit dem video leuten teilen
abonnieren nicht vergessen ich habe
nämlich bald die 500.000 geknackt also
bitte
helft mir und sonst hier sind noch zwei
videos schreibt was nettes in die
kommentare vielleicht welches outfit
euch am besten gefallen hat ich denke
die entscheidung ist ganz klar gut bis
dann eure mal war